en mai 2002, j'ai été interrogé par la
cia et le fbi et ils ont menacé si je
ne coopérais pas de m'envoyer soit en
egypte soit en syrie
pour être davantage torturé
[musique]
je pense qu'il est tout à fait clair pour moi que la
réponse des états-unis à la  les terribles
attaques du 11 septembre étaient une vengeance la guerre
contre le terrorisme n'est pas une opération policière c'est une
opération militaire pourquoi ils m'ont attaqué
ce n'était pas seulement moi ils ont attaqué
tout
le monde
faisait en afghanistan, ils amenaient des
gens sur ce site de torture
euh afghans afghans ordinaires euh
et les
abusaient en dehors de l'état de droit
, puis permettaient à certains d'entre eux de
rentrer chez eux et ils rentraient chez eux et
disaient aux gens que c'est ce que les américains ont
fait
[Musique]
ce qu'ils voulaient que je fasse, c'était de signer
une confession disant que j'étais membre d'Al-
Qaïda, ce que je n'étais pas
et c'était
je dirais la norme, je l'ai compris,
je pense que je l'ai mieux compris que beaucoup
d'autres prisonniers  nous avons été dépouillés nous
ont été battus on nous a craché dessus nous avons été
humiliés des photos de nous ont été prises
pendant cette période ils ont eu
le bruit d'une femme
euh dans la pièce voisine qui m'a amené à
croire que ma femme était torturée ils ont fait
signe avec des photos de mes enfants
devant moi
[Musique]
nous avons enseigné ensemble et nous avons fait des
événements ensemble
et tous sont contre la guerre
tous disent que leurs amis et
collègues et euh ceux qui sont morts sont morts en
vain j'ai rencontré et reçu des messages de  tant
de soldats américains
demandent dans certains cas en fait
implorer pardon
[Musique]
je pense que les États-Unis d'Amérique
doivent prendre du recul euh s'ils veulent
aider le
peuple afghan, cela ne devrait pas être
conditionnel à euh
ce n'est pas  en mesure de négocier
ces conditions, il a été un
agresseur avec les États-Unis et la
Grande-Bretagne en particulier, je pense qu'ils se
sentent très contrariés parce que c'est une
défaite, c'est une défaite militaire, mais
vous w  ant à le regarder
[Musique]
vous